اتهم القضاء في ولايه جورجيا الامريكيه
الرئيس السابقه دونالد ترامب و18 اخرين
بالابتزاز وارتكاب جرائم اخرى بهدف قلب
نتيجه الانتخابات رئاسيه الماضيه في
الولايه وقد ندد ترامب الذي يواجه رابع
قضيه هذا العام بهذه الاتهامات واعتبرها
ملفقه وزائفه ومسيسه واكد انها تستهدف
حملته لتمثيل الحزب الجمهوري في انتخابات
الرئاسه المقبله
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم خبر حلقتنا ولا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما هي التداعيات السياسيه
والقانونيه الاتهام ترامب بمحاوله قلب
نتيجه الانتخابات في جورجيا وكيف سينعكس
على فرصه في نيل بطاقه الترشح للرئاسه عن
الحزب الجمهوري كيف ينظر الناخب الامريكي
ومانحوا حملات ترشح الحزب الجمهوري لهذا
الاتهام الجديد والى اي مدى سيؤثر على
حاله الاستقطاب المحتدمه اساسا في المجتمع
الامريكي ما تاثير هذا الاتهام على مهمه
بايدن في حمله اعاده انتخابه وكيف سينظر
اليه الشارع الامريكي في ضوء اتهامات
معسكر ترامب اداره بايدن بتاسيس القضيه
[موسيقى]
مستندا الى قانون المنظمات الفاسده
والممارسه للابتزاز ومبهدا لرابع دعوه
قضائيه يواجهها الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب خلال سته اشهر اقرت هيئه
محلفين كبرى في ولايه جورجيا الامريكيه
اتهام ترامب و18 من مساعديه بالسعي لقلب
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه الماضيه في
الولايه وبحسب الادعاء في جورجيا فان
ترامب وبقيه المتهمين سعوا لتحقيق اهدافهم
من خلال التورط في الابتزاز وجرائم اخرى
بلغت في مجملها 41 وتضم ايضا الادلاء
بتصريحات كاذبه وتقديم وثائق مزوره
وانتحال صفه موظف عام والتزوير والضغط على
شهود وارتكاب سلسله من الجرائم
المعلوماتيه وتقديم شهادات زور
من جانبه لم يتاخر في نفي الاتهامات
الصادره من جورجيا بل واعتبرها ملفقه
وزائفه اختير توقيتها بصوره قصديه للاضرار
بحملته الكاسحه وفق قوله للترشح عن الحزب
الجمهوري في انتخابات الرئاسه المقبله
واتهمت ترامب المدعيه التي قدمت الدعوه
ضده في احدى مقاطعات ولايه جورجيا بانها
تعمل لصالح الرئيس جو بايدن وهو ما نفته
بدورها مؤكده انها تعمل استنادا الى
الوقائع والقوانين
[موسيقى]
مناقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا في واشنطن مع
السيد ادولفو فرانكو المحلل الاستراتيجي
في الحزب الجمهوري والدكتور ليون فريسكو
نائب مساعد وزير العدل الامريكي السابق
مرحبا بكما دكتور ليون هذه القضيه الرابعه
ضد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب منذ بدايه
العام ما الذي يميزها عن القضايا السابقه
بتقديرك
فارق الاكبر الذي يميز هذه القضيه هو
اتساعه نطاقها وعدد الجرائم التي اتهموا
الرئيس السابق باضافه ثمانيه عشر من
مساعدهم مما يجعل هذه القضيه مختلفه كثيرا
عن الثلاث التي سبقنا والتي كانت خفيفه
وصغيره بالمقارنه هذه التهم تهم تامر
واسعه النطاق طالت كثيرا من الاشخاص في
عدد من الولايات لكن جورجيا كانت الولايه
الرئيسيه الفارق المهم الاخر هو ان الرئيس
اذا ما فاز في الانتخابات القادمه لا
يمتلك اي الضمانات ليحصل على عفو منها اذا
حتى لو فاز فربما قد يضطر الى قضاء فتره
في السجن ما لم يعفو عنه
محافظ جورج ايضا سيد ادولفو هل تقلق هذه
القضيه معسكر الرئيس ترامب
اذا كان نازل في الحقيقه هناك قلق عندما
يكون هناك لوائح اتهام تواجه ولكن يجب ان
نوضح بعض الامور الضيف الاخر يتحدث عن
امكانيات السجن الى اخره هذا الافتراض انه
لمجرد وجود اتهام او سلسله من الاتهامات
ان
المذنب ولكن ليس هذا النظام في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يجب ان نفهم ان الهيئه
المحلفه في توجيهها للاتهام تقوم بعمليه
سهله ومن الطبيعي ان يكون هناك توجيه
للائحه الاتهام عندما يكون هناك عمل على
مستوى الادعاء العام هناك جهه واحده تقدم
الادله الا وهي الادعاء لذلك لائحه
الاتهام السهله هناك مؤامره في الحقيقه
وهي مؤامره الديمقراطيين الذين عملوا
والمدعون اقروا بانهم كانوا يعملون مع
بعضهم البعض وكانوا معينين او منتخبين من
قبل الديمقراطيين على المستوى السياسي
وحتى وزاره العدل اداره بايدن هي التي
عينتهم اذا ان محقق الخاص هو
يرفع تقارير لشخص معين من قبل السيد بايدن
باضافه الى ذلك هناك اشاره الى قانون
المنظمات الفاسده والممارسه للبتزاز وهو
نحن نتحدث عاده عن مجموعات من الجرائم
المنظمه نعود بها الى قانون الحرب الاهليه
الى اخره هذا سخيف من المنظوري القانوني
كل ذلك لا اساس له لا اساس لهذه الاتهامات
وهناك صوابق واسعه النطاق في التاريخ
الامريكي نعود الى اذا سمحت ساتحول
للدكتور اليوم من جديد دكتور بالفعل هي
اللائحه تستند الى قانون يعرف اختصارا
بريكو وهو يعني يستهدف مباشره العصابات
والمافيات هل في هذا اشاره دكتور
اليه هذا الامر انه في خاتمه المطاف هناك
اعتقاد بان هناك كيانا قد تم انشاؤه ضم
عده اشخاص في هذه الحاله ثمانيه عشر شخصا
اضافه الى الرئيس السابق في محاوله لسرقه
نتيجه انتخابات اذا عندما يقولون ان
مجموعه من الاشخاص التاموا سويه لارتكاب
جريمه نعم انتم محقون هذا يتم عاده في
محاولات فرض تاوات وابتزاز وسرقه لا يحدث
عاده في عمليه سرقه نتائج الانتخابات بشكل
نموذجي لكن هذه ظروف فريده من نوعها
والسؤال هل القاضي
والمحلفين في هذا القضيه سيتفقون ام
يختلفون مع قناعه
توجيهي اتهام الرئيس السابق بانه قاده
مؤامره من شانها سرقت نتيجه انتخابات او
لا قلت بان هذه القضيه هي مؤامره ولكن
المدعيه في جورجيا تستند الى مكالمه
هاتفيه ما بين الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ومسؤول في جورجيا يطلب منه ترامب ان يتدبر
له اثني عشر الف صوت لكي يغير النتيجه في
الولايه كيف يمكن لهذا ان يندرج ضمن
المؤامره
سوف اجيب عن ذلك بعد دقيقه ولكن اود ان
اوضح بعض النقاط التصريحات المرتبطه بسرقه
الانتخابات هيا غير مناسبه من قبل الضيف
الاخر هو يحتج على نتيجه الانتخابات وهو
حقا انا ممارس في القانون التجاري وانا
اعرف قانون المنظمات الفاسده والموارثه
للابتزاز وهذا القانون لا يستخدم في هذه
الحالات السيد سميث استخدم نظريات قانونيه
في حالات سياسيه سابقه في الولايات
المتحده وتم عكس القرار من قبل المحكمه
العليا بشكل كامل
وتوافق الاراء ما من سرقه هنا هو يحتج على
نتيجه الانتخابات بالنسبه الى سؤالكم حول
الاتصال في اللغه الانجليزيه
يتوقف الامر على تفسير على سبيل المثال
يمكن ان يطرح السؤال هل يمكن ان نجد
اصواتا ولكن لم يستخدم صيغه الامر جد
لهذا الكم من الاصوات اذا بالنسبه اليك
كمحام الارتكاز الى الاتصال هذا لا يؤدي
الى قضيه متماسكه ويجب ان نمارس في هذا
السيد ادولفو هذه معلومات ام تحليل يعني
من هذا المنطلق سيدفع الرئيس ترامب
ببراءته من هذه الاتهامات بانه لم يطلب
وانما كان يسال عن امكانيه
نعم نعم هو يقول ويدفع ببراءته بناء على
ذلك وهذا طبيعي لانهم من ضمن حقه يمكنه ان
يحتج على نتائج وان يستفسر بشان النتائج
والتاريخ يثبت ان باستطاعه المرشحين ان
يحتجوا الديمقراطيون قاموا بالاحتجاج
وقالوا ان انتخاب السيد ترامب غير شرعي
غير قانوني بما في ذلك رئيسه مجلس النواب
السابقه وتحدثوا عن سرقه الانتخابات
واختطاف الانتخابات من قبل الروس ومن احد
تحدث عن هذه الامه دكتور ليون الرئيس
ترامب يسال لماذا لم تفتح هذه القضيه قبل
حوالي سنتين ونصف لماذا الان لانه هو يشكك
ويقول بان الهدف منها الان هو استهداف
حملته الانتخابيه للانتخابات التمهيديه
بالحزب الجمهوري كيف يمكن الرد على هذا
الكلام
ما يخطر في بالي هذه الاتهامات ان يقول
الامر متروك لهم ان يفسر نواياهم لكن
السؤال هل هذه التهم يمكن اثباتها امام
محكمه ام لا في خاتمه المطاف لو ان المدعي
العام
شعره بنيه صادقه بان الرئيس لم يكن يتساءل
عن نتيجه انتخابات بل شعر انه خسرها وحاول
يغير النتيجه وحتى لو علم انه قد خسر
فحاول تغيير النتيجه اذا المدعي محق في
المضي قدما بتوجيه هذه التهم
لاننا نريد ان نثبت ايضا انه لن يسمح
لرؤساء الاخرين ان يحاولوا التشبث بالسلطه
حتى عند خسارتهم الانتخابات هذه القضايا
جاده وتستغرق وقتا طويلا هي ليست نتيجه
جهد يوم واحد هناك تسعه عشر متهما
جنائيه وهناك اخرون لم توجه لهم التهم اذا
هناك الكثير من الوقت والجهد والطاقه قد
بذلت لاتمام مقتضيات هذا القضيه
والتسعين صفحه التي تضمنتتها لائحه
الانتخاب ولا اعتقد انه امر يمكن ان يتم
في عجاله الرئيس ترامب هو الذي قرر في
النهايه هل سيترشح للانتخابات ام لا اعتقد
ان مثل هذه القضيه
تحتاج كل هذا الوقت لا يمكن ان تسقط في
عجال بالتالي سيد ادولفو هل من انعكاسات
محتمله لهذه القضيه والقضايا الثلاث
السابقه
على حظوظ حصول الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
على بطاقه الترشح عن الحزب الجمهوري
الفرص الحظوظ هي ترتفع في حقيقه الامر بان
يصبح الرئيس السابق ترامب المرشح الجمهوري
كل
الاستطلاعات تظهر انه من المنظور الجمهوري
هذه ملاحقه غير عادله وهذا يؤدي الى رفع
منسوب شعبيه الرئيس السابق ولكن هذا لا
يتوقف عند حدود الجمهوريين ان نيويورك
تايمز في استطلاعات الراي تثبت في يومنا
هذا حتى قبل الانتخابات تعادل الاصوات بين
السيد ترامب والسيد بايدن وحتى ان السيد
ترامب سبق السيد في
الاستطلاعات اذا هذا واضح انها ملاحقه غير
عادله هذه القضايا كان يمكن التقدم بها من
قبل التوقيت يؤشر الى مؤامره من قبل
الديمقراطيين للقيام بامرين
ولن عدم امكانيه ترشيح السيد ترامب او
ترشح السيد ترامب لقد اساؤوا الحساب
برايهم يمكنهم ان يقيدوه من خلال هذه
القضايا في المحاكم وهو واجه قضايا في
السابق وهذا غير مسبوق هذا التدخل في
الانتخابات والرئيس ترامب محق هم يحاولون
ان يسقطوا المعارضه من خلال استخدام اذرع
الحكومه ضد الخصم السياسي هذه الحقيقه
المره في الولايات المتحده الى جانب ما
قاله السيد ادولفو معسكر رئيس ترامب يقول
بان البيت الابيض يستخدم وزاره العدل
لاغراض سياسيه لاستهداف الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامبو حملته الانتخابيه ما واجهت
هذا الكلام
خاتمه المطاف هذا امر متروك للمحلفين
والقضاه الذين
سيراسون المحاكمه لقياده هل هذه الاتهامات
مشروعه وهل الحقائق التي تذكر والوقائع
دعما لها تتماشى مع القانون ام لا في
الحقيقه
لن ليس من الحكمه ومن السابق الاواني ان
السابق الامور لكن من واجب الوزاره ان تضع
مدعيا خاصا لهذه القضيه وهو الذي قرر
وضع هذه القضيه
والمبتدع العامه وزير العدل قبل هذه
الدعاوى والامر متروك للمحلفين
للقضى هل هم الذين
الرئيس السابق مذنب ام لا ولا يمكن لاحد
ان يستبق الاحكام لكن الامر المهم هو ان
الرئيس ترامب عندما طلب اليه التسليم
وثائق كانت في حوزته في عده مناسبات وكانت
له فرصه كافيه لم يقم بذلك سنعرف هل
المحكمه ستدينه بسبب ذلك
هذه القضيه الا يخشى ان تحول الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب بنظر مريديه وانصاره
الى ضحيه وبانه يستهدف فعليا في هذه
المرحله لحرمانه من الترشح وبالتالي تزيد
من حده الاستقطاب الموجود اصلا في الشارع
الامريكي بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
السؤال لك دكتور ليون
من الصعوبه بمكان ان نحسب هذا الامر من
دون ان نرى الرئيس وهو ماثل امام المحاكمه
هذا امر لم يمر على هذه البلاد من قبل وفي
الاشهر المقبله هناك احتمال ان تشرى اربع
محاكمات وان يحاكم رئيس بتهم جنائيه هذا
امر على الشعب ان يقرروا هل هذا سيجعل منه
ضحيه او هل هو يتعرض لقمع او مكائد ام انه
رئيس فعل ما لم يفعله اي رئيس سابق وانا
الاوان لان ننتقل الامام ونتخلى عن رئيس
مثل ترامب له كل هذه السوابق لا استطيع
احد يمكنه ان يتكهن بالنتائج وكيف سيشعر
الراي العام بعد اربع هناك الكثير من
الاحتمالات سيدي ادولفو بتقييمكم في الحزب
الجمهوري وانت محلل استراتيجي في الحزب
كيف تفهمون تصدر الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب السباق على الصعيد الحزب الجمهوري
وبفارق كبير
في مقدمه اقرب منافسيه رغم كل هذه القضايا
التي رفعت بحقه حتى الان ما هو التفسير في
الحزب الجمهوري
في الحقيقه هذا بالضبط ما اشير اليه نحن
نتحدث عن
استهداف غير عاد الناس ليس عليهم ان
ينتظروا للمحاكمات هم يرون ان هناك مطارده
غير عادله للرئيس ترامب وانا محامن واعرف
هذه الامور يحاولون ان يقيدوا الخصم وهي
تصبح اي الولايات المتحده كجمهوريه موز من
خلال محاوله اسكاتي الخصم ان الاستطلاعات
تظهر شعبيه رئيس ترامب في اوساط
الجمهوريين والمستقلين كذلك لان الناس
اذكى هم
لديهم معرفه ويعرفون ان هناك استهداف
للرئيس السابق وهذا لا يؤدي الى نتيجه
المرجوه منه وبالتالي هذا نظام فاسد
يستهدف من خلاله رئيس رفاودته من المش ان
يفهموا ان السيد السميث ليس مستقلا هناك
فرق بين المحقق الخاص المستقل
والسيد اسم هو
يتم رفع التقارير من منصبه لوزير العدل
وزير العدل هو معين سياسيا السيد السميث
ليس مستقلا هذه نقطه اساسيه ونعود الى
النقطه الاخرى التي لم نتحدث عنها الضيف
الاخر تحدث عن السيد ترامب والوثائق التي
كانت بحوزته
كان لديه وثائق عندما كان سيناتورا لم يكن
لديه حق فيما الرئيس ترامب كان لديها الحق
كانت الوثائق في مرابه اين المحقق واين
المحاكمه واين لائحه الاتهام لم يحرك
ساكنا لاشهد بالنسبه الى هنتر بايدن كذلك
لم يحرك القضاء ساكن فقط الان بعد الضغط
وبعد كل الادله التي ظهرت تم تحريك القضيه
وضع هنتر تحت الاضواء اذا اجابه عن سؤالكم
هناك كيل بمكيالين في الولايات المتحده
هناك نظام عداله للديمقراطيين الذين
يستخدمون النظام القضائي كاداه سياسيه
ونظام الذي يحاكم من خلاله ترامب ان رئيس
ترامب سوف يكون المرشح للحزب الجمهوري
وسوف يكون الرئيس التالي للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اذا كانت هذه القضايا ولائحه
الاتهامات تاتي بنتائج عكسيه ولصالح
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كما يقول على
الاقل السيد
ادولفو هل لها انعكاسات على المعسكر
الديمقراطي في سياق محاولاته
للاحتفاظ بالبيت الابيض والفوز بولايه
ثانيه مثلا
مره اخرى اقول نحن لا نعرف هل ان لهذه
القضاء ستكون لها ارتدادات عكسيه او لا
يجب ان نرى كل محاكمه وكل قرار سيتخذه
الشعب استنادا لما يقدمه الى المحلفين من
ادله انا اعلم ان هذا امر نادر بل غير
مسبوق واعمل ان تكون كل هذا القضايا تتم
امام
الشاشات التلفزه لكي يرى الناس في بلدنا
وفي العالم ليقرروا هل هذه الاتهامات
والمحاكمات مشروعه ومبرره ام لا الذين
اعترضوا يمكن ان يقولوا هل ان هذه التهمين
لم تكن مبرره فسيكون
هناك كلفه سياسيه كبيره
لمن قام بهذا القضيه لكن اذا ما تمت نجحت
محاكمه س
على الطرف الاخر في النهايه لا احد يفعل
كل هذه الامور وكل يواجهون كل هذا
الصعوبات من دون اطار نحن كبد كانت هناك
مواقف كثيره وضعها الرئيس ترامب وضع البلد
فيها عاده ما كانت ستكون هناك ايه حاجه
لمثل هذه
الاتهامات لكن ما فعله هو لذا ذلك وفي
النهايه سنرى هل كان ذلك من العدل بمكان
ام لا
بالاجابه لو سمحت المدعيه في جورجيا تسعى
لان تبدا المحاكمه في غضون سته اشهر
بتقديرك ما هي استراتيجيه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب للمواجهه باقتضاب لو سمحت
بعض الامور اولا لكي نكون واضحين بالنسبه
الى البث المباشر لهذه المحاكمه فريق
ترامب دعا للبث المباشر لتدابير المحاكمه
وبالتالي ليس للسيد ترامب ما يخفيه وهو
يطلب ذلك ثانيا كمحاما يمكنني ان اقول لكم
ان هذه المحاكمات لن تجري وفقا لهذا
التوقيت الذي اشرتهم اليه ومن منظور اعطاء
الفرصه للتقدم بالدفوع لا يمكن الدفاع في
حالات متعدده في قضايا متعدده وكل لوائح
الاتهام هذه هذا غير عادل اذا رؤيه اربع
محاكمات في نفس الوقت او شكرا تسلسل هذا
غير منطقي
شكرا لكما شكرا السيد ادولفو فرانكو المحل
الاستراتيجي في الحزب الجمهوري والدكتور
ليون فريسكو نائب مساعد وزير العدل
الامريكي السابق شكرا لكما الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء بامر الله
[موسيقى]